Oh baby the Chris Sims podcast I think
it's just so fitting that my first guest
will be Kyle Shannon you know you're the
first guest of my podcast in oils first
wear that no you sure you want to get
out now I just have a feeling these are
fake and this is even a ghost there's no
way you got your own the bizarro world
right now did you ever see this in my
future at any point did you ever go you
know chris has got a big mouth I think
he could pull this out you are you do a
lot of customers the first guest on
unbuttoned the new Chris Sims that's
what we mean by unbuttoned on Monday and
the irony is you always button up to the
top yeah sure it on there under beds
buttoned all the way to the top there it
is there he always in character since he
was 8 years old Chris Sims buttoned to
the top that'll be fun it will be fun
and thanks for the invitation to be
honest yeah like any time you're invited
yes seriously and it's fun just to be a
part of the family in general but I am
excited about the podcast and I'm
excited about working with you I don't
know how you feel about it but you have
to deal with me so sorry for any chances
to veto you did and I try you have that
out you tried as I said you don't have
much power this company that you can
veto me like that today today is
officially official zit man waxman board
four times a week starting next week
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports